ajusta el ángulo y el radio del número
complejo graficado en anaranjado para
que coincida con el número que se
muestra en azul - 2.6 menos 1.5 x y
observa qué pasa con el número complejo
al cambiar el radio y el ángulo que lo
representan así que tengo este número
este puntito naranja y lo tengo que
hacer coincidir con este punto azul que
representa a este número complejo de
aquí al menos 2.6 menos 1.5 x y entonces
tengo el problema planteado en
coordenadas rectangulares y quiero
pensar en él en coordenadas polares
vamos a ver vamos a modificar primero el
ángulo si el aumento noten como el
puntito naranja comienza a moverse sobre
un círculo
y parece que están más o menos en la
misma dirección que el punto azul ahora
sólo tengo que incrementar el radio
recuerden que cuando se está trabajando
con números complejos normalmente al
radio se le conoce como el módulo y al
ángulo como el argumento del número
complejo entonces tengo que si pongo el
radio igual a 3 y el ángulo igual a 7
sextos de pi obviamente esto está medido
en radiales entonces parece que los dos
números coinciden vamos a verificarlo
por nosotros mismos de que me voy a
copiar
voy a copiar la pantalla
a copiar esto
voy a pegarlo por acá vamos a moverlo
ahí bien entonces mi radio la distancia
que hay del complejo al origen del
módulo es 3 y el ángulo que tiene ese
número complejo es decir esta magnitud
de este ángulo que normalmente se
representa por la letra griega fi es de
7 sextos
bien entonces sí recuerdo un poco yo sé
que este número complejo su
representación polar la puede escribir
como 3 por a las 7 sextos siete textos
de pi por iu y después si utiliza la
fórmula de oyler obtengo que esto es
tres veces a las siete sextos por people
y es lo mismo que coseno de siete textos
de pin 17 sextos de pin más y veces el
seno
de 7 sextos de pie
7 sexto de ti bien de hecho aquí ya lo
tenía escrito no lo tenía que haber
vuelto a escribir pero bueno entonces
cuánto es el coste no de 7 sextos de pi
déjenme dibujo un círculo unitario
plano cartesiano
si hay una gran diferencia esto que
estoy dibujando es el plano cartesiano
usual y este es el plano complejo aquí
los ejes son el eje imaginario y el eje
real mientras que acá son el eje x y el
eje i
pero bueno déjenme pongo mi círculo
unitario
más o menos algo así y aquí voy a voy a
marcar un ángulo de 7 sextos de pi si
llego hasta el eje x negativo abre el
recorrido pin para llegar a 7 sextos de
pi
sólo necesito un sexto y primas entonces
un sexto de primas algo así de modo que
este ángulo de aquí vale
un sexto de pie
un sexto o lo que es lo mismo 30 grados
pero bueno lo que quiero hacer es
encontrar la coordenada xy la coordenada
de este punto así que empecemos con la
coordenada x con el coseno de ese 7
sextos de pie cuanto vale eso pues si
extraigo este triangulito de aquí me lo
hago con un color un poco más
contrastante acá abajo
estoy en una situación algo así
este ángulo de aquí es precisamente el
que vale un sexto de esta longitud que
te hipotenusa el triángulo vale 1
y yo sé que si este ángulo vale un sexto
como este ángulo recto este ángulo debe
valer dos sextos de pi por lo tanto
estoy en un triángulo en un triángulo y
sextos pi tercios y un recto por lo que
yo sé de trigonometría elemental que
esté a este cateto el cateto opuesto
perdón el cateto adyacente al ángulo de
un sexto debe valer precisamente raíz de
tres sobre dos esa es la magnitud pero
tengo que tomar en cuenta la dirección
como voy hacia los negativos serían
menos raíz de tres entre dos
y la coordenada de cuánto sería la
coordenada y yo sé que va a ser un medio
pero de nuevo voy hacia los negativos
así que sería menos un medio
de modo que tengo que esto este número
es igual a lobo ya qué color podría
funcionar para los dos croques d
voy a reescribir todo esto de acá como
es por el coste de 7 sextos de piqué
digo que es menos raíz de 3 entre 2 raíz
de 3 entre dos más y veces
y veces
el seno de 7 sextos de pie pero escenas
7 sextos de pies menos un medio entonces
más y por menos un medio
bien entonces si hago toda esa
multiplicación obtengo 3 por menos raíz
de 3 - 3 raíz de 3 entre 2
3 x menos un medio es menos 1.5
por ti de modo que al menos las partes
imaginarias del número azul
de este número coinciden vamos a checar
que la parte real también coincide con
mi calculadora ok entonces menos 3 por
la raíz de 3 entre 2
- 2.59 8 lo cual si redondeo es
aproximadamente menos 2.6 por lo tanto
este número es aproximadamente menos 2.6
menos 1.5 y que es precisamente el
número que queríamos